[Musik]
im Laden von Cristiano dalmatheo
herrscht Ruhe seit Monaten geht das so
der Geschäftsmann im südsudanesischen
Tonch sitzt vor seinem Shop und wartet
auf Kunden Cristiano verkauft vor einem
Zucker und Mehl doch seit Krieg in der
Ukraine herrscht sind die Preise
gestiegen können sich viele seine
Produkte nicht leisten
der Krieg in der Ukraine trifft uns weil
der Preis des Dollars angestiegen ist
Benzin und alles kostet uns
letztes Jahr waren die Preise unten seit
dem Ausbruch hat sich alles verteuert
wegen dieses Krieges in der Ukraine
überall in Afrika sind die Preise vor
allem für Mehl und Sonnenblumenöl in den
letzten Monaten in die Höhe geschossen
der Südsudan bekommt Lebensmittel über
die Nachbarländer die aber essen als
erste ab ein Sack Mehl kostet etwa
doppelt so viel wie zu Beginn des Jahres
für viele zu viel
sie leiden es gibt einige die haben gar
nichts sie können sich nichts leisten
einige haben keine Arbeit haben keinen
Job viele Leute leiden zu viel
wie sehr sie leiden erfahren wir hier im
kleinen Krankenhaus von tonsch jeden
Morgen sitzen schwangere und stillende
Frauen unter einem Baum und warten auf
Schwester Boll ackerboll ihr Maßband ist
ihr wichtigstes Utensil entscheidet über
zusätzliches Essen
den Oberarmumfang weniger als 23 cm
bedeutet Mangelernährung die Klinik
versorgt die Mütter mit Zusatznahrung
gespendet von einer NGO viel gibt es
nicht mehr
wir mussten feststellen dass unsere
Spenden um 30% zurückgegangen sind
[Musik]
wir haben Personal verloren
und wir haben andere die uns helfen
verloren
unser Budget ist gekürzt worden wegen
des ukrainenkrieges
das Krankenhaus wird überwiegend mit
Spenden amerikanischer und britischer
Hilfsorganisationen finanziert deren
Aufmerksamkeit aber ist jetzt anderswo
im fernen Europa dabei ist im Südsudan
mehr als die Hälfte der Bevölkerung
Mangel ernährt spitzt sich die Lage
durch anhaltenden Regen und
Ernteausfälle weiter zu auf den Gängen
sitzt Monika niaru mit ihrer neun Monate
alten Tochter seit zwei Tagen hat die
junge Mutter nichts mehr gegessen
ich bin seit zwei Tagen in der Klinik
und niemand bringt mehr Essen von zu
Hause es gibt kein Essen ich habe nichts
weil es zu Hause auch kein Essen gibt
und daher können sie mir auch nichts
bringen
lange Zeit waren die Lieferungen aus der
Ukraine und Russland auch nach Afrika
unterbrochen als in der August wieder
das erste Schiff mit 23.000 Tonnen
Weizen in shibuti an landete war da zwar
Erleichterung doch die Liefermengen
seitdem sind viel zu gering
wir wollen mehr Nahrungsmittel sehen wir
brauchen aus unserer Perspektive
Millionen von Tonnen in dieser Region
allein in Äthiopien kommt dreiviertel
von dem was wir verteilen aus der
Ukraine und Russland
im südsudanesischen Tonch versucht
Assunta Adio die Hilfe der
Nichtregierungsorganisationen zu
koordinieren allzu viel kommt derzeit
nicht alles ist schwierig im jüngsten
Staat der Welt die politische Situation
die Versorgungslage die Transportwege
der Krieg in der Ukraine trifft das Land
nun in einer ohnehin katastrophalen Lage
wir haben Krieg in der Ukraine das
trifft unsere Partner sie helfen nicht
wir geben Ihnen unsere Einschätzung und
bekommen keine Antwort wir versuchen
alles um den Menschen zu helfen aber die
NGOs helfen uns aktuell nicht wir haben
keine Hilfen von unseren Partnern weil
sie kein Geld haben
der Südsudan ist eines der ärmsten
Länder der Erde die Überschwemmungen der
letzten Jahre haben die Situation immer
weiter verschlechtert gerade die
Landbevölkerung die sich lange Zeit
selbst versorgen konnte hat wenn
überhaupt nur noch das Nötigste der
Wechsel von Dürren und anhaltenden
Regenfällen haben die Ernte weitgehend
vernichtet
ans hast du dann hast du da ist so etwas
wie eine vergessene Krise geworden
gerade jetzt wo der Bedarf sehr sehr
hoch ist wir haben mehr als 12 Millionen
Einwohner und jetzt sind 8,9 Millionen
Menschen auf humanitäre Hilfe angewiesen
das ist eine Herausforderung und die
Situation könnte sich weiter
verschlechtern das Fürchten
schon im letzten Jahr waren die Preise
für Weizen in Ostafrika um ein Drittel
gestiegen seit Ausbruch des Krieges um
weitere 30%. die Inflation liegt in
vielen Ländern über 20 Prozent hinzu
kommen die hohen Benzinpreise die den
Transport teurer machen und damit auch
Lebensmittel das trifft ohnehin arme
Länder wie auch den Südsudan doppelt
der Preisunterschied ist riesig und das
in einer ohnehin schwindenden Wirtschaft
das hat das Leben hier sehr sehr
schwierig gemacht und ihr Arbeit zu
leisten
das ist die Situation
einige NGO mussten ihre Arbeit im
Südsudan bereits zurückfahren weil ihre
Mittel gekürzt wurden Spenden in die
Ukraine gegangen sind für das noch
vorhandene Geld bekommen sie jetzt
außerdem immer weniger waren weil die
Preise auf dem Weltmarkt gestiegen sind
so verkaufen sie auch am Markt von
tonnensch nur noch das Wenige was das
Land selbst hergibt Okraschoten Zwiebeln
Erdnüsse denn alles was importiert wird
ist für die Menschen hier viel zu teuer
dieser Krieg trifft uns denn wir haben
keine eigenen Fabriken oder irgendetwas
wir kriegen alles von außen und wenn
nichts hereinkommt haben wir nichts hier
der Krieg in der Ukraine ist fast 7000
Kilometer entfernt vom kleinen tornsch
im Südsudan doch seine Auswirkungen
spüren Sie auch hier steigende
Lebensmittelpreise und
Versorgungsengpässe werden die Situation
von Millionen Menschen noch einmal
dramatisch verschärfen
noch nie war der Hunger im Südsudan so
groß und so bedrohlich und dass ich
lebensmittelkrisen auch negativ auf die
Entwicklung von Demokratien auswirken
können das kann man momentan in Tunesien
sehen das Land steht kurz vor dem
Kollaps unsere Korrespondentin Anna
Warsberg war dort ihren Bericht seht ihr
hier aber auch im reichen Europa können
sich immer mehr Menschen immer weniger
leisten in Großbritannien zum Beispiel
müssen sich viele Fragen heizen oder
Essen unser Korrespondent Andreas Stamm
hat die Menschen getroffen hat euch das
Video gefallen dann lasst gerne ein Like
da und abonniert diesen Kanal